It was quite an experience for all of us to
get to hear him.
And it is equally very fortunate now to have
Wayne Hale who has had a very illustrious
career at NASA.
Wayne came to NASA the same year I did in
1978, worked his way up as an engineer through
the propulsion system, the integrated communication
systems.
Became a flight director in 1988 and served
there for 15 years.
He was flight director both for the orbit
phase and then the most really kind of intense
flight control phase as ascent and entry.
And Wayne was ascent and entry flight director
and then lead flight director for many flights,
including-- we were trying to figure out before.
But I think he actually served for all of
my last four flights.
So we've known each other for a long time.
In 2003, he was sent to the Kennedy Space
Center to be head of launch operations.
But he didn't get to spend very much time
in the Florida sunshine because they asked
him to come back to Houston the next year
as deputy program manager for the Space Shuttle.
And then, when Bill Gerstenmeyer left to move
up to NASA headquarters, Wayne became the
program manager.
So he is able to talk to us both about Mission
Control operations and the current and future
state of affairs of the Shuttle.
And he is very happy to have you ask questions
while he is talking.
And I am not going to talk anymore because
they came to hear you, Wayne.
WAYNE: Thank you, Jeff.
I cannot tell you how much I've been looking
forward to coming here to talk to you folks.
This is my favorite subject.
Space, number one.
The Shuttle, number two.
And Mission Control, number three.
Maybe not exactly in that order, but they
are all three topics that have been--
[NOISE OBSCURES]
Oh, that was you.
I thought that was me.
I thought that's a sound I haven't heard before
and I'm in big trouble.
OK.
But, as Jeff said, please feel free to ask
any questions.
I will tell you all kinds of interesting stories
today, I think.
Some of them might even be about Dr. Hoffman.
I should tell you my background as an engineer.
I got my bachelor's and master's degree in
mechanical engineering.
Did not decide to pursue a doctorate degree
for a variety of reasons.
You need to understand that the organization
of NASA is very much around the centers.
It was organized as a group largely of independent
centers with a very thin veneer of integration
at NASA headquarters.
And it remains that way to this day.
And every center is quite different from every
other center.
We have some centers that are largely involved
in research.
And, if you want to work in the research center,
Langley, Glenn, Ames then you need to clearly
pursue a PhD.
If you're more interested in an ops center,
Kennedy, Marshall, Johnson, then you need
to kind of not go after the PhD.
Because people with PhDs clearly do not have
a real world practical understanding of problems.
And it is only the guys with bachelor's degrees
that get out and know how to turn wrenches
in their spare time required there.
So it is very interesting, the different cultures.
I can say that with a grin because there are
different cultures within NASA.
And working between the centers is very interesting.
And since I have moved in the management ranks,
for what reason I don't understand, I have
fouled up in my career.
[OVERLAPPING VOICES]
make you a manager when you don't get to do
the things that you're good at anymore.
Yes, promote you something that you were never
trained for.
It has been very interesting for me to try
to work between the various centers to help
them accomplish the goals that the agency
has.
One of the things I should say is that I regret
my academic career as I didn't take more psychology,
more accounting.
Because, frankly, when I was in graduate school,
I can remember one of the courses I had was
systems of nonlinear partial differential
equations.
Anybody taken a class that has a title vaguely
similar to that?
I never used that class.
I have never touched a differential equation
in my professional career.
Now, why that is, is kind of interesting.
But what I really did need was trigonometry
and accounting.
And you will see a little bit of that.
Today my class is not going to be highly technical.
It is going to be a series of illustrations
about Mission Control.
And, as I said, I will be happy to talk to
you about it.
I go to a lot of conferences these days, and
I frequently sit in advanced space systems
sessions.
I sat in a very interesting future reusable
launch vehicle session the last AIAA conference
I went to.
And I walked away totally distressed because
they have no concept of what the real world
is like in many of these academic seminars.
And I want to inject a little bit of real
world realism into what you guys think about
as engineers.
One of the favorite topics of people these
days that are designing advanced space systems
include what they call and "austere" launch
pad.
In other words, you cannot fix anything on
the rocket when it is on the launch pad.
And the reason they side is look how much
money all these programs spend fixing their
rocket out on the launch pad.
Well, the fact of the matter is rockets are
very finicky, rockets have very little margin
in many of their components and things break.
They can break and you don't even know it
until you plug them all together and turn
them on.
And if you have a launch pad that is austere
and you can do no work on it, well, what was
one of those colorful phrases that Chris Kraft
would use?
You have really bought the farm.
I won't use his colorful phrases.
You wind up spending a lot more money because
you've got to take the rocket back to the
barn and take it all apart rather than maybe
get access to fix it.
If there was anything that I wish we had was
more capability to fix things on the launch
pad.
We spend a lot of time and money working around
problems that we cannot fix at the launch
pad, even though we have a huge amount of
capability.
You don't save money there.
It is a false economy.
Similarly, there is a notion en vogue that
you don't need a big Mission Control.
That is just a lot of people that cost a lot
of money that you don't really need.
I think it reached the height of the anti
Mission Control forces during the DCX program
when they were very proud to proclaim their
Mission Control was a trailer house with three
people in it.
And they thought that was all any space vehicle
needed to have to launch.
Of course, they only reached an altitude to
5000 feet and they crashed their only prototype
vehicle, not because of Mission Control but
perhaps because they didn't pay enough attention
to operational situations.
In my business now, I can tell you that in
the Space Shuttle program Mission Control
cost me less than 2% of the total budget for
the Space Shuttle program.
What we get for that 2% is quite amazing.
And every time the budget folks come down
from Washington to review our budget, they
want to help us drive down the ops cost, they
take one look, you have the budget breakdown
of the Shuttle program and they say you guys
don't spend very much on ops.
This is not where we need to look if we want
to save some money.
If you want to save some money, you need to
make a reusable vehicle.
Reusable and not so maintenance intensive
to turn it around.
And that may be a theme that you hear today.
I've got a couple of things I want to pass
out to get started, a couple of glossy brochures.
I think there are enough of these for everyone
about Mission Control.
People in the class should get first dibs
at this, but hopefully there are enough to
go around.
I think there are plenty of these.
And the little one is similar to the big one.
And I'm not going to spend a lot of time.
If you want to know about how Mission Control
Room is laid out and who the people are that
do things, it's all in this brochure.
I don't intend to go over that.
I think Chris Kraft probably gave you a good
background about why do we have a Mission
Control.
Why did he invent a Mission Control?
And this is kind of the nuts and bolts of
Mission Control as it exists today.
Public Affairs Office is really good about
putting those things together, and I don't
intend to cover them.
Also because I had a whole bunch of copies
of my last two papers sitting around that
I needed to get rid of, I lugged them up here.
I want to give you copies of my last two papers
which have to do with operational issues that
you can read at your leisure.
And I particularly want you to look at the
considerations in rendezvous launch windows.
Those are two different papers.
One discussing entry operational considerations
and hypersonic entry that we've learned with
the Space Shuttle.
The other about rendezvous launch windows.
And it will give you a little flavor for what
a real operation needs.
Many people can talk to you about the physics,
kind of the things that God says you must
do if you are going to rendezvous in space,
for example.
But there are many other considerations that
you run into in the real world.
So I am going to talk today mostly about Mission
Control.
Perhaps at the end we can talk a little bit
about the Shuttle program.
And these I am short of so, please, people
in the class only as my handout for the slides
here today.
And the slides will be posted on the Web as
well.
Yes.
Dr.
Hoffman has got them off my electronics here.
OK, so the things I am going to talk about
today basically are outlines on this page.
We have a Mission Control.
Here are some of the reasons we are going
to talk about trajectory.
Planning and monitoring flight planning.
Systems engineering.
And then I've got a couple of stories from
the trenches.
And then I promise you no differential equations
today.
Question.
Why should you have a Mission Control?
Why is it necessary to have a Mission Control?
I have four basic reasons to have a Mission
Control.
The first one is safety.
We have seven or eight astronauts flying arguably
the most complex flight vehicle that has ever
been invented.
They don't have enough time or enough resources
to watch everything to the degree that is
necessary.
We have a large group of folks on the ground
in Mission Control, about 800 folks in Mission
Control that are also monitoring at a very
detailed level with more information than
the astronauts get to make sure that everything
is operating as it should be.
We provide a level of safety in Mission Control.
Secondly, we provide flexibility.
We start planning a Space Shuttle Mission
typically about 18 months in advance.
The flight operations people are the flight
planning people, so the Space Shuttle program,
NASA headquarters will come down and say you
need to fly a Space Shuttle flight that does
X, services the Hubble Space Telescope, deploys
the Chandra X-Ray Telescope, goes to the International
Space Station and adds a module or carries
supplies or what have you.
Then it is up to the planners who will become
the operators to put that plan together.
How are we going to accomplish the big objectives
on this flight?
It's not just enough to take this big module
up and plug it into the Space Station.
You've got to wire it up.
You've got know when to do which wire first
and what switch to throw in what order or
you will fry the circuits.
It's a very complicated business.
It is really complicated when you have to
deal with scientists.
So, when we fly scientific payloads, we deal
with folks that are not operationally minded.
They may have been working on their experiment
for, oh, how long did it take to get a doctorate
degree, 15, 20 years in some cases.
They have been working on this experiment
for many years.
They are going to get the maximum amount of
data they can, but they are not aware of the
fact that there are four other payloads onboard
and four other competing folks that want to
get their science data in.
We always have a discussion about how many
person hours of astronaut time can we devote
to an experiment?
How many kilowatt hours of power can we devote
On and on and on.
And it makes these researchers do some really
tough sole-searching.
And the saddest thing that I have ever seen
is an experiment, and there has been more
than one of them, where they flipped the switch,
it blew the fuse, it was down for the count
and lost all objectives with the first switch
throw.
And then the scientists would come running
and in and say if you'll just let the astronauts
take the back panel off and rewire this circuit
it will work.
And we don't have time to do that on a spaceflight.
Or, if we did have time to do it, we would
take that time away from experimenter number
two or experimenter number three or all of
the above.
In operations, there is a lot of work to set
priorities, set timelines, make sure you do
things in the right order, and then train
the operators and the crew.
Now, once you do that planning for 18 months
you understand the priorities, the pros and
cons, the logic behind all of those trades.
And so, when you go into flight and something
happens, as it always does, we can re-plan
it on the fly.
And we do, almost every flight or the vast
majority of flights, take the flight plan
that we published pre-flight, put it gently
in the recycle bin and develop a new flight
plan that can be drastically different.
And we're able to achieve a great degree of
success in our operation of the objectives
that we set out to do because we have the
people that can, in real-time while we're
flying the flight, in this short period of
less than two weeks overnight re-plan and
come back with a new plan to accomplish the
objectives.
Yes sir.
Wayne, I was one of those scientists who didn't
understand about the realities of spaceflight.
And I liked your choice of the words "you
would discuss with us".
Dictate would be the key word.
Indeed.
The question I wanted to address to you is
this business of taking the flight pad, putting
it in the wastebasket and then generating
a new one.
In the seven Shuttle flights that I would
have investigator status on, they all had,
as their basic philosophy, a return to baseline.
If something went wrong, get back to your
baseline plan as quickly as you could, even
if you knew that it was non-optimal.
Could you comment on that?
I would say, from my perspective, quite the
opposite.
Yes, there is a baseline plan.
And there were very good reasons for that
baseline plan.
But the flight control team is always looking
for the optimum solution.
So I would say my perspective may be a little
bit different from yours, but that has been
my experience.
We are always trying to achieve the maximum
number of objectives.
So flexibility from Mission Control is the
second big advantage.
The third big advantage is let the crew focus
on those things that people can only do in
space.
They have access to vacuum.
They've got zero gravity.
They've got the high vantage point to do earth
observations, what have you.
You cannot do those things on earth.
That is why we put people in space.
And why would we make them calculate the gas
budget for deorbit burn which can be done
by some bachelor of science engineer with
an accounting minor on the ground?
So we let the crews focus on those things
that you can only do in space and we do every
job that we can on the ground.
Somebody calculated for me one time, and I
almost hate to give the statistic, that it
is $30,000 a minute for people in space.
You can hire a lot of engineers to offload
that amount of time.
And, finally, there are some jobs that you
can only do on the ground.
The NOAA weather satellites do not directly
uplink to the Shuttle so the astronauts don't
know anything about weather, other than the
little part of the world they can see out
their window.
If you want to forecast where you land, that's
a job that you can only do on the ground.
Obviously, radar tracking there are hundreds
of things that you can only do on the ground.
And I would say interact with management and
review the priorities is one of those things
that can only be done on the ground.
Here is my first cartoon for the day that
compares airline travel to space travel.
And I think this is a telling cartoon because
it is entirely true.
I flew in last night on probably a 12 or 15
year old 737.
It was a nice plane but a little shabby.
And we got bumped around pretty good coming
into Boston.
And I am thinking all the time about I wonder
if they have maintained this aircraft well.
You can pick up the papers.
And they do a very good job in the airlines,
but the fact of the matter is much of the
airline industry is involved with passengers
and customer relations and baggage handling
and all those good things.
And the maintainers and the safety people
are few by comparison.
In comparison with the Shuttle, we don't have
very many passengers to deal with.
Generally, they are cooperative.
Sometimes they get surly.
But we don't have very many to deal with.
And everybody in the program is a safety worker.
And that is something we continuously exercise.
To turn a Space Shuttle orbiter around from
one flight to the next takes 500,000 man hours
of maintenance.
There is a gem for you.
People have been working for 30 years to decrease
the amount of time that it takes to turn the
Space Shuttle orbiter around.
It is a reusable vehicle, but it is a reusable
vehicle built with very small margins with
a lot of complicated technology.
And it takes a lot of maintenance.
Some people think we would have been better
launching expendable rockets.
The same amount of time, actually, a little
more is involved in launching Titan IVs which
have the same payload throw weight as the
orbiter does to low earth orbit.
The new launch vehicles Atlas V, Delta IV
and its variance are supposed to be launched
with a whole lot less.
However, they do not have the payload capacity
to orbit.
And, in fact, they have not achieved their
goals of man hours to a launch that they have
set out to yet.
Although, they are early yet.
We've got to give them time to work on it.
But, the fact of the matter, getting into
space, whether you doing with an Ariane, a
Soyuz, an H2 or an Atlas V, Delta IV or the
Space Shuttle remains a very expensive process
which I think the public doesn't quite understand.
I would like to talk about some of the things
that Mission Control does to get ready for
a flight and then how they execute it in-flight.
And first among those is trajectory control.
Who in here is an orbital mechanics wizard?
Good.
OK.
We will have some equations for you in just
a minute.
Here is the first one.
Would you like to step up and explain?
OK.
This is all involved in orbital mechanics.
This is how do you get to orbit?
We have the flight performance reserve of
main propulsion system propellant.
We load a half a million gallons of propellant.
That is over 2.5 million pounds of liquid
hydrogen and liquid oxygen in the external
tank for the Shuttle.
How much do we have for a normally planned
mission at the end of when you achieve orbital
insertion?
Anybody want to guess?
Remember, every pound of propellant that you
leave in the tank and throw away into the
ocean is a pound of payload that you could
have carried to orbit.
So this is not a trivial process.
Our goal is about 900 pounds.
And you are going to see how we do.
But this is a little plot that we've developed
based on mixture ratio of the engines.
Now, the Space Shuttle main engines have what
we call an overboard mixture ratio of 6.039
nominally.
We test fire them at the Stennis Space Center,
every engine for every flight, to check how
they operate mixture ratio because mixture
ratio and ISP are critical.
When we updated the Space Shuttle main engines
to the block two engines they are vastly safer
than the original engines in the Shuttle because
they operate at lower pressures, lower temperatures
and their rotating turbo machinery operates
considerably slower RPM.
However, we gave us a second and a half of
ISP.
And that is huge in this business, a second
and a half of ISP.
This plot shows, as a function of mixture
ratio, if you have any shift in mixture ratio
in flight, which we have, I'm going to talk
a little bit about that, you will change the
amount of residual remaining.
Here the
little blue dots are the normal flight performance
reserve.
That is how much gas you've got left in the
tank when you get to orbit.
And you can see our goal here is about 2500
pounds.
Of that about 900 pounds is fuel residual
based on this curve right here.
Now, you may ask why do you want to have an
extra amount of hydrogen fuel in the tank
over oxygen, what is the difference?
The engines are designed, the cutoff hydrogen
rich.
We don't operate at the stoichiometric chemical
ratio that you would combine hydrogen and
oxygen to make water.
We operated at about a mixture ratio of six
instead of a mixture ratio that would be 18,
I think.
Did I do my chemistry right?
It's been a while.
We operate considerably off the stoichiometric
ratio.
As you get mixture ratios that approach the
stoichiometric mixture ratio your fire burns
a lot hotter.
You get a lot more heat out of that fire.
Metallurgically, the engines cannot stand
those higher temperatures.
We already operate at 6000 degrees Fahrenheit.
That is tough.
You run out of fuel and cut off oxygen rich,
those temperatures will go out of site in
the engine turbo pumps.
So we want to cut off fuel rich.
We biased ourselves so we cut off fuel rich,
but it does not take very much of a mixture
ratio shift to get you to cut of LOX rich.
In fact, as mixture ratio crosses the knee
of this curve, you wind up leaving actually
a lot of LOX in the system cutting off on
the fuel side.
So we have to carefully monitor how the engines
come in.
And, when we talk about overboard mixture
ratio, that is not just what the engines operate
at, but it's whatever losses you have in the
system.
As you bleed hot hydrogen or hot oxygen off
the engines to repressurize the tank, that
becomes a loss and that affects mixture ratio.
One of the real problems we're dealing with
is, as we develop what we call engine tags
down at the Stennis Space Center, we have
found an interesting phenomenon.
In flight, we pressurize the tanks with their
native constituent, the oxygen tanks pressurized
with oxygen and the hydrogen tanks pressurized
with hydrogen.
At Stennis, where we do the engine tests and
develop the characteristics of each engine,
and every engine is just a little bit different,
they pressurize their tanks with nitrogen
for safety reasons.
The nitrogen can diffuse into your hydrogen,
but more importantly it can diffuse into your
oxygen system.
And, therefore, you have a less pure propellant
and it drives our mixture ratio off as a function
of having impurities in the propellant.
So we get a tag of what we think the mixture
ratio is of the engine.
That is different than what we get when we
go fly.
And, in fact, the last flights, one of the
last meetings I had before I came down here
yesterday was a meeting with our flight analyst
who have an unexplained missing 300 pounds
of hydrogen every flight for the last 10 or
12 flights.
And we are beginning to converge on the idea
that it is this nitrogen impurity in Stennis
that gives us a false mixture ratio which
we design our flights around.
Let's talk a little bit about it.
Here is a little schematic.
The external tanks really have two tanks,
the oxygen tank on top and the hydrogen tank
on bottom.
When we make it to orbit, how much is remaining
in each tank?
Well, the answer to that question is none.
What we are running on at orbit insertion
is what is left in the pipe.
And it is really not orbit insertion but close
enough to talk about it.
So we have 17 inch diameter pipe coming down
the side of the hydrogen tank from the oxygen
tank up above.
It goes across into the engine compartment
of the orbiter.
And this shows you where several of the early
flights were at main engine cutoff, guided
cutoff where we wanted to be from an orbital
mechanics standpoint, altitude velocity, flight
path angle and so forth.
That is where we were.
That is how much was remaining in the tank.
None in the tank.
That is how much is remaining in the line.
That is how close you have to cut it for spaceflight.
I have another presentation, and if we have
time I might show you a few charts out of
that, that talks about the difference between
commercial aviation and spaceflight.
We operate on much smaller margins.
And every pound you see in that far part of
the table that talks about the residual remaining,
those number of pounds, and, by the way, we're
antiques.
We use English tradition units in the Space
Shuttle program.
But every pound residual that you have in
that far column is a pound that you could
have taken to orbit of payload but did not.
You threw that away.
Yes.
How do you measure that mass?
Very good question.
They look at pressure hit.
We have pressure transducers down in the lines
as they approach the engine and you're accelerating
at 3G.
We have an inertial measurement unit that
measures velocity, and we control the engine
throttle setting to 3Gs as we approach MECO.
And so you look at the pressure and that determines,
based on a very simple head calculation, where
you are in that standby coming down the outside.
The fuel side is a little bit more complicated.
They have a 5% level sensor in the tank that
tells you when you're at 5% in the tank.
And then we have fuel flow meters on the hydrogen
side, and they calculate flow rate minus from
the 5% level down to when a main engine is
cut off.
So those are the ways we can do residual.
And that is not a simple exercise.
It is vastly more complicated than the simple
explanation I just gave you because the engines
are throttling continuously.
Now, I wanted to talk a little bit, if I can
move from normal mission planning to abort
mission planning.
Normal mission planning is something we do
upfront and then we monitor during flight.
And one of the stories at the very end of
this presentation is about a day when things
did not go right in the engine world and what
we did about it.
This is going to talk about abort modes.
Now, the Shuttle is very interesting.
Human spaceflight is different than expendable
spaceflight because we would really like to
get the people back.
And expendable spaceflight, your basic principle
is if one of the rocket engines quits early
you are done.
The payload goes in the water.
Or, if you launch from
[NOISE OBSCURES]
it may go into Mongolia.
But you don't get it back.
There are no overs with very few exceptions.
If you have a problem in your main propulsion
system on an expendable rocket it is time
to talk to your insurance company because
you are done.
Even very minor problems can strand satellites
in lower orbits than they have useful life.
It is very important that the propulsion system
work well.
But the Shuttle was designed with the thought
that one of the three main engines could shut
down early.
We have safety monitoring on those engines
to make sure that they would shut down if
something goes wrong in a contained, that
is to say they don't blow up, manner.
And then you have to have the capability to
get the crew back, much like an airliner.
If you fly on an airliner or any kind of multi-engine
aircraft, one of the things that they must
be certified for is engine out operations.
Lose an engine, pass the commitment point
on takeoff and still be able to takeoff safely
and return to the airport.
That is a fundamental principle in aviation
safety for a multi-engine aircraft.
One of the Shuttle design goals is very similar.
Lose one of the rocket engines, have it shut
down prematurely and still be able to land
safely somewhere.
Notice I said one engine.
Not two engines.
Not three engines.
One engine.
That is a huge technological leap over expendable
rockets.
A huge technological leap.
And we pay the price in terms of performance.
Here is a little bit of the different abort
modes.
If you have an engine out somewhere between
launch and about four minutes into flight,
you have to return to the launch site which
involves turning around and flying backwards
at mach 6 through your own rocket plume, which
is everybody's favorite thing to want to avoid
doing.
A little bit later than that we pick up the
capability to do transatlantic abort.
Sometimes we call the transoceanic aborts,
but the acronym really is transatlantic abort,
TAL.
And land somewhere in Europe or Africa.
And somewhat further along you can abort to
orbit.
You can actually dump your secondary propellant
and wind up in a lower orbit.
And then you may orbit once around or you
may come back on the third orbit.
Or you may be able, in fact, to fly nearly
a normal mission depending on how lucky you
got for the time that the engine was out and
how you were doing with reserves.
Here is a little bit of different graphic,
a cartoon of the same thing.
I don't like it too much because RTLS actually
turns the other way.
But, as you can see, we would try to return
to the Kennedy Space Center which has possibly
the worst weather in the entire western hemisphere
or continue on around or up on end to orbit.
And you have to always be concerned about
external tank disposal.
This was the abort regions chart generated
pre-flight for our last flight, STS-114.
We have three TAL sites, transatlantic intact
TAL sites, one at the Zaragoza Air Base in
North Spain, one at Moron Air Base in South
Spain near Seville and one at Le Tube which
is the French Air Force Flight Test Facility
near Marseilles.
And then we have what we call "Press to ATO".
Press to abort which involves a dump, involves
changing your inclination of your orbit to
a lower inclination if you invoke this.
You cannot, for example, ever rendezvous with
the Space Station because you won't wind up
in the right orbital inclination, even though
you may make the altitude.
And then we have what we call "Press to MECO"
which involves just kind of closing your eyes
and riding it out and see what happens as
you get close to your guided MECO.
So we build these charts in advance.
And then we have a very sophisticated computer
program in Mission Control that monitors the
engines the entire time during launch called
the "abort region determinator" that can emulate
a single engine out, two engines out, three
engines out or a vacuum impact point.
And a flight dynamics officer is responsible
for making those calls.
The crew does not make these calls.
The crew has a crew card very similar to this
onboard so that if they lose communication
with the ground and something bad happens
they might have a chance at pulling it off.
But it is based on everything more or less
performing as planned.
If anything is performing off normal than
these charts are no good.
That is hosted in Mission Control.
And until some day we put a supercomputer
onboard the space vehicle it will continue
to be hosted in Mission Control.
Do you have a question?
Yes.
That is a critical real-time call that is
made in a hurry.
It is not always decision aid.
Can you comment a little bit on the reliance
upon the automatic decision aid computer that
is grinding this out and the judgment of flight
control?
Well, first of all, you have made a false
distinction because the people that wrote
the computer code are the flight controllers.
They understand the logic that went into it
with practice probably three days a week in
Mission Control exercising simulated missions
that have engine problems so you practice
that.
It's not an either or.
It's a symbiotic relationship.
The abort region determinator doesn't work
without operators.
Operators only have the cue cards to go on
if the abort region determinator software
quits.
You cannot get by without the other.
There is some judgment involved.
And a good flight dynamics officer with these
charts, with no
[UNCLEAR]
can make some judgment calls based on trends
and performance.
But we need both.
You cannot have one or the other.
It is very sophisticated.
It is very subtle.
And very small changes can make this software,
this predictor work.
It is probably the best example of an expert
system that I know of, but it takes a great
deal of care and feeding.
And it is very, very sensitive to the inputs.
So it does take a lot of judgment and experience
to interpret.
Along with that, we need to talk about where
you land.
Because here are all the places.
We kind of closed down Banjul and the Gambia
because we don't fly that inclination anymore.
We do fly at the International Space Station
Missions, and we have the TAL sites I talked
about.
We could fly as high as 57 degrees inclination,
which we have done in the past, but that is
outside the range of what we need to do for
the Space Station.
The interesting thing is we get into the weather
story and the weather forecasting, and deciding
which landing site you can go to is pretty
complicated.
I never studied meteorology in college.
It is another subject I wish I had.
That is not all.
We talked about intact abort landings if one
engine quits.
But being good flight planners and controllers
you always take it to the next level.
What if two engines quit?
What if all three engines quit?
And so we have made agreements all the way
up the East Coast of the United States with
the Canadians to have places to land.
And, again, we have agreements with all of
these landing sites.
We send people to train them about what would
happen if the Shuttle would land there.
We check the weather.
Across the Atlantic we have landing sites.
Again, Shannon, Ireland was probably the first
dry patch of land that you can come to on
the far side of the Atlantic Ocean.
Typical weather conditions there are 500 feet
overcast and rain and fog so we don't really
probably want to use that.
England is a little better.
Cologne Bonn is a little better.
And then we have all of these landing sites
that we can look at.
And that keeps the State Department busy for
us because we have to have international agreements
to use any of these places.
It took us two years to negotiate with the
French government for emergency use only of
their landing site.
We typically don't have people at these landing
sites other than our intact TAL sites, Moron,
Zaragoza and Istres-Le Tube.
But they are there.
We would not hold the launch up if one of
the landing sites for two or three engines
out was not available, but we would if we
did not have an intact landing site which
is the one engine out requirement.
So we have requirements difference.
One of the really fun things is when we get
into the summer months we frequently cannot
use some of these airports because they have
air shows going on.
And they would really like us to land the
Shuttle there during an air show, but we don't.
One of the things that we have to watch very
carefully is where do we get rid of the external
tank?
Now, we can carry the external tank to orbit.
There have been some very colorful viewgraph
presentations put together of using the external
tank as parts for a Space Station.
Totally science fiction.
Operationally it would be extremely difficult
to do.
Carrying the tank to orbit would be very easy,
but we stopped just short of orbital velocity
so that we can control the disposal of the
tank.
We now have international treaties that say
you shouldn't put things in orbit without
being able to put them in a place where they
don't hurt people.
We don't like to have satellites reenter and
drop radioactive garbage or even just big
hunks of metal on top of people, so we have
the external tank that we separate and drop
just short of orbital velocity and use the
small orbital maneuvering engines on the Shuttle
to provide the last couple hundred feet a
second to get to orbit.
And we have to plan this very carefully.
We've done a lot of studies to find out when
that tank will rupture, how big the pieces
are, how far they've come apart.
And we actually have flight rules talking
about ET disposal.
This is a serious subject.
Everybody that flies an expendable rocket
has to know where their stages are going to
fall, except maybe the Russians who just drop
them in Kazak or used to.
I grew up in New Mexico in the 1970s.
We were very excited about the thought that
White Sands might be the launch site for the
Shuttle when it was under early design phase.
When they picked solid rocket boosters that
fell off just a couple hundred miles downrange,
we knew that White Sands was out of the running
because that would put people at-risk in the
continental United States.
And those kinds of decisions make for launch
site decisions.
Yes sir.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
We're talking a little less than an hour.
Probably about 45 minutes from managing cutoff
to the rupture at about, let me see, let me
make sure I say that right, 122 kilometers.
I don't operate in kilometers.
I have to do the math, but it's not long.
It's less than one orbit.
One orbit taken 90 minutes.
It's about halfway to two-thirds of the way
around the world that we get rid of the tank.
And this is a very important subject.
In fact, US laws and the Eastern Range that
we have to work with to get launch clearance
issues what we call "Notice to Airmen" or
"ET disposal" about 48 hours prior to the
Shuttle launch to clear the ocean area and
the air space.
And this is all based on what we call a normal
main engine cutoff.
We made our guided cutoff to orbit.
And here is a little picture of a problem
we had earlier I want to talk about.
Here are the ET disposal lines for the different
inclinations.
You can see that some of these get kind of
close to the West Coast of Mexico, but most
of them fall out in the Pacific Ocean.
And, in particular, here are the Space Station
lines for disposal of the external tank.
And, as we go through the five minute launch
window, the inclination of the orbit -- Not
the inclination but the steering the Shuttle
has got to do to reach the Internal Space
Station changes the place where these tanks
are disposed of.
I think I have a better picture.
And, in particular, we had a problem with
this little island right here that we were
infringing on the internationally recognized
200 nautical mile limit for pieces.
Now, if we do a normal insertion, you will
see that we have these typical nominal footprints
based on where we were in the launch window.
That is where all the pieces will fall.
But we have dispersions based on trajectory
and other dispersions that say we've got to
clear to a 99.7% probability this whole area,
or this is the area that results from all
the dispersions at that level.
So we don't want to drop pieces on people.
Once upon a time, the United States Air Force
thought that Pitt Island down here was a bird
sanctuary and nobody lived there.
And they sent out the Notice to Airmen to
clear the area, and we found out there are
a couple of hundred people that live on this
little island and the Australian government
got kind of bent out of shape over that.
We had to negotiate infringing by just a few
miles on the 200 nautical mile circle around
these guys just at the toe of the footprint,
and that went back to the French government.
And that took us two years to negotiate.
So they don't teach you everything you need
to know in engineering school like negotiating
with the French.
JEFF:
[BEGINS SPEAKING WITHOUT MICROPHONE]
...disposal probability to your average diplomat,
like you say, we don't get training for that.
Way beyond.
Now, here is my funny story number one.
Dick Richards, who was program manager before
me, was asked to go on speaking engagement
to American Samoa.
Now, I've been asked to speak a lot of places
and they are always like Boston or, you know,
OK, this is a nice place to come, but think
about a speaking engagement in American Samoa.
So he had to go to American Samoa to speak.
And, as they got ready to leave, the airline
pilot came on and said we cannot take off
because they are going to launch the Shuttle
today.
He had seen these tanks come in.
He was not about to violate that airspace
that they have been notified.
And the launch time would put him past the
point of no return where they had to continue
onto Hawaii and could not turn back to American
Samoa, so he wasn't going to take off until
he got word that the Shuttle had either launched
or scrubbed for the day.
And there was a delay.
And so Dick Richards got on his cell phone
and called to Houston and found out that we
were sitting on the ground in Florida based
on bad weather at the TAL site at Banjul and
the Gambia.
The passengers started talking about this.
And they said you mean here we are in American
Samoa waiting on a Shuttle launch from Florida
that has been delayed because of bad weather
in West Africa?
The answer is yes.
So, what you do has an impact all around the
world.
OK, enough about trajectory.
And I have quite a lot I could talk about.
Let's talk about flight planning.
One of the interesting things that we do onboard
the Space Shuttle is we carry a lot of laptop.
At last count, I think we carried about 11
laptops on the last flight.
But we don't rely on those laptops because
they keep breaking.
What we rely on is paper.
Spacelab flights are worse.
I'd say the typical Space Shuttle flight that
launches carries 80 pounds of paper checklists.
Every one of those pages lovingly crafted.
We got maps and charts and we got all kinds
of little cue cards that stick up on Velcro
all around the cockpit, but by and large they
come in books, and here are some of the books.
And Mission Control folks build those books,
understand those books, can modify those books
in real-time, and frequently do.
One of the things we have to watch is printer
paper onboard because we cannot run out of
printer paper when we update checklists.
And so we have to monitor how much paper we
are using as we print out changes to the checklists
onboard.
Yes sir.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
In so far as paper can be made low flammable.
It is but it is paper and it will burn.
The Shuttle cockpit is full of flammable stuff.
But it is tried to kept under control.
It is tried to be protected.
And, of course, we don't operate in a pure
oxygen atmosphere as Apollo did.
It is very much like earth normal atmosphere.
So, no, it is not fire proof.
I wish it was.
When we start a flight, we start out with
what we call a flight requirement.
Here is the flight definition requirement
document.
Here is the flight we just flew and the basic
parameters that we've got.
Which orbiter are we going to fly?
The next flight up we're going to fly Atlantis.
Which external tank is TBD?
Because we're still arguing about that.
Which solid rocket booster pair, so on and
so forth?
Which main engine by serial number?
Which flight software release?
How many cryogenic tanks do we have the arm
onboard and all this stuff?
What is the manifest?
Well, it is a station manifest for the utilization
flight 1.1 which has got an MPLM.
It used to be called the Miniature Payload
Logistics Module.
Now it is the Multi-Purpose.
That transmigration of acronyms over time
have become more politically correct as a
subject for a doctoral thesis, I think.
Which launch pad we're going to operate out
of?
And how many days are we going to fly?
How many people?
We're going to carry seven up, six down, land
at KSC and a bunch of remarks.
This is kind of the basic definition.
This is the starting point for a flight.
This is what we get to start.
And then we have to flush those out.
We build a word document and we talk about
the requirements for a flight.
This is done at the program level.
What is the launch window?
What is the launch period?
And many of these things are just flushing
out the basic requirements you saw in the
chart.
Here is an interesting one, part of that flight
requirements document that talks about EVA
spacewalks and talks about what we're going
to do.
And you will notice, in great bureaucratic
language, the purposes of the EVAs are defined
in another document that you have to go off
and look at.
So, they're not any flight requirements documents
but at least you got a reference where to
go.
And here are some of the things we are going
to be able to do on this flight.
And, in fact, we're going to have some contingency
or emergency EVAs that can do these emergency
things, which we hope we don't have to do
but we are going to be prepared to do.
From that we develop flight rules and flight
plans.
Here is a page out of the flight rules book
that the ops people built.
This is discussing how we take pictures of
the external tank.
You saw those beautiful pictures just a few
minutes ago of the tank taken by the Shuttle.
And here are the guidelines.
We're going to have to do a thrust from the
plus X jets, but we won't do it if we've got
problems in the propellant system, if we are
way under speed, if we're going to be dark
because we don't have a flash that big, and
so on and so forth.
And then that's the automated umbilical well
camera.
And then we've got the handheld photography.
And we've got a whole bunch of reasons why
we wouldn't do that.
If we had to go to a backup software, we don't
want to do that because it makes it too sporty,
just all kinds of reasons.
Bob's people are thinking about this all the
time.
And, in fact, it's not enough to have the
rule.
Here is the rationale behind that rule.
Why is it we decided you would or would not
take those pictures which are very important
to us for post-flight analysis on a very detailed
level?
Anything you see in italics font is what we
call flight rule rationale which is the subject
of interminable meetings and lots of haranguing
and wrangling.
Here is a little bit of the inspect rule.
We all know that the thermal protection system
on the Shuttle is not as robust as we would
like it to be.
We are going to inspect it every time.
Here are the priorities that are planned before
flight for thermal inspection system.
And we start with the most important and we
work to the least important.
Your goal is to do them all but your plan
is to have a plan ready if you run out of
time.
And then, again, the backup of why did we
say that.
And, again, it is more inspection priorities.
I am not going to go over all of these.
You can look at them.
I want to come back to EVAs for a minute.
Here are some of the EVA task objectives.
This is something that they did just the other
day onboard the International Space Station.
This happens to be an International Space
Station rule, but it is closely related to
the Shuttle rules.
They put in a new camera group.
All this is perfectly clear to you guys, all
these acronyms.
It takes about six weeks to learn the language
when you come to work at NASA.
And then we have something on the Station
called the floating point potential measurement
device which is broken and became junk and
they threw it overboard just a couple of days
ago.
Well, you get through all the rules and you
come to a flight plan.
And here is the flight plan.
This is from the last flight.
Eileen Collins, here is what she is doing
this particular day.
This is flight day number three.
This is what the pilot is doing.
Some time I will have to tell you the difference
between pilot astronauts and mission specialists.
Dr.
Hoffman has his PhD.
He well versed in many things.
And the pilot, Jim Kelly, one of my favorite
guys, I like him a lot, flies jet planes so
he gets post-sleep exercise.
And so we have all the guys.
And what they are doing by the hour of the
day, and this is the overview, by the way,
but these guys are going out on a spacewalk.
And so here is their EVA preparation, purging
their suits, getting setup, going out the
door.
Here is the EVA which are going to be outside
for 6.5 hours.
And this particular day they're doing the
thermal protection system repair detailed
test objective which you saw in the rules
as one of the priorities.
So, we build this level of flight plan.
Now, this is not it.
We go to the minute-by-minute level, detailed
checklist, this is the overview.
This is kind of OK, you've got to get up and
brush your teeth and make breakfast and then
go do some work kind of thing.
And then we have all of our other procedure
and checklist to make sure everything goes
as perfectly as it possibly can.
And this is just A day.
And then we get all kinds of good little information
down here.
One of which is when we're going to be able
to communicate with the astronauts.
There was a revolution in flight control when
we launched the Tracking and Data Relay Satellites.
Before we had Tracking and Data Relay Satellites
and you just had ground stations to communicate
with the crew, we could talk to the crew about
15% of the time.
85% of the time they were out of communications
with the earth.
Now, if you were going to the Moon and you
used a Deep Space Network, you pretty much
had continuous comm.
But if you were doing Shuttle or any other
low-earth orbit kind of thing you could only
talk to the crew for about 15% of the time.
And sometimes it lined up that you would talk
to them three or four minutes every hour and
a half.
The Russians have a huge problem in that they
lost all of their tracking stations outside
of geographical Russia.
And so they talk to their crew and plan their
crew day on those parts of the orbit where
they come over geographical Russia.
And they are a slave to that.
And we launched the Tracking and Data Relay
Satellite.
Now we can talk to the crew all the time.
There is virtually no time you cannot talk
to the crew.
The crew gets really tired of that.
They want to shut the radio off because Mission
Control is always calling up and yammering
at them.
But it is a revolution because now we can
get continuous data, communications and command
with the crew from the ground.
And the bottom line on that is we're much
more efficient.
We don't have to wait for critical activities
to happen until we get that communication
link.
Yes sir.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
Mars there are going to be four to 20 minute
time delays in communications one way.
Yes.
What are the preliminary plans for dealing
with that?
I don't know.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm serious.
A lot of people are really worried about that.
It will be a different way to operate.
And the folks that are working on those programs
have got a real challenge.
Two quick questions.
One is if you time the checklist, I mean do
you know how long page three is going to take?
Absolutely.
And the other thing is do you have backup
flight plans for every contingency pretty
much where you know if this experiment fails,
per se, we will pull out this flight plan
and it reschedules everybody?
No.
In fact, what we do is we have some emergency
checklists.
If you develop a leak in a cabin, OK, here
is the emergency drill checklist to get you
back on the ground as soon as possible.
But the flexibility that I talked about in
Mission Control is no, we don't build complete
different timelines.
Say if experiment A doesn't work we have a
different timeline.
What we do is we have the smart people in
Mission Control that can take the existing
timeline and build a new one.
And, in fact, they do almost every night.
I call it night.
That is when the crew is asleep.
It could be daytime in Houston but it is when
the crew is asleep.
The last thing I want to talk about in a flight
preparation.
Yes.
If the crew fall asleep at the same time,
isn't that not a bad idea in case something
goes wrong?
Shouldn't someone be keeping watch?
Mission Control is watching, A, number one.
And, B, number two, there are enough automatic
sensing.
The computer is watching the really vital
things so that if you've got a link in the
cabin, if you've got fire, something like
that happens, the alarms will go off and wake
the crew off.
One of the case studies I am going to show
is when Mission Control didn't get to watch,
so look for that in a minute.
The post-sleep period?
Ask Jeff.
The post-sleep period is what do you do after
your alarm clock goes off?
There is cleanup, shave, get dressed and make
breakfast, which is a huge deal.
This is not like taking something out of the
freezer, throw it in the microwave and eat
it.
It's a huge deal to cook and cleanup onboard.
Personal hygiene time.
It's also time that most crews spend reading
the morning mail.
They don't get a newspaper but they get reams
and reams of paper off the printer from Mission
Control.
You thought you were going to do an EVA today,
but here is what we're really going to do.
It's a really important time, getting ready
for the day, so we allow the crews about an
hour and a half of post-sleep activities.
And that is everything to get to work.
Yes.
How do you decide what to tell the crew and
who makes that decision?
Well, that's an interesting discussion.
The flight director, of course, is in overall
charge.
I should say that there are three shifts of
flight controllers in Mission Control, who
are not ironmen, but that work about 9 hours.
There is an hour handover period, and so three
shifts a day cover the day.
A flight director is in charge of the team.
The flight planners, big flight activities
officer we call them, obviously have a big
part of this.
On a day like this when it's an EVA day the
EVA officers have a big part of this.
The CAPCOM, capsule communicator which is
held over from Mercury days, is an astronaut.
And hopefully a flown astronaut.
Not always but typically a flown astronaut
that is the crew's representative in Mission
Control.
And the CAPCOM is a very valuable resource
in saying here are things the crew would want
to know, here are some things the crew already
knows so we don't have to tell them.
Here you've built a plan that is going to
overwork the crew or here you've built a plan
that has got people sitting around with a
lot of white space not doing anything getting
bored.
So, it becomes a team effort.
Finally, the flight director approves all
uplink messages.
Yes.
[AUDIENCE]
...when do you tell the crew about that and
who decides?
Well, again, it is a team so it's not this
military hierarchy that orders come from the
top.
There is a team.
The team will develop here is what is happening,
here is what we think we're going to do.
The stories come together enough and here
is the judgment factor.
The flight director will tell the CAPCOM to
tell the crew in basic terms what the crew
should know.
Now, we have a lot of ways to communicate
with the crew.
And the Shuttle we are very fixed, obsessed
with doing things on an open air to ground
because in the old days they did some things
kind of pine that got came out in press conferences
that were bad.
The station crew has got this IP phone, Internet
Protocol phone and they can call you.
Like right now if they had your phone number.
They can just call you and talk on the phone,
and nobody knows what's going on.
We have email with the crew.
And a lot of things go up on email, but all
of those communication paths are utilized
to get information back and forth to the crew.
I probably ought to tell you one little short
story.
This is my sports analogy story so you will
have to put up with that.
Working in Mission Control is like working
in different sports.
If you are the ascent entry shuttle team it
is like playing basketball full court press
all the time.
You are always running short time but very
intense.
If you are a shuttle on orbit it is kind of
like American football.
You huddle up, figure out what play you're
going to do, go out, execute the play, it
worked or it didn't work, you come back, huddle
up.
It is very episodic but it can happen fast
when it is happening, when you're executing
it.
The Space Station is baseball.
It's a very much different game.
And one of the hard things as you move as
a flight control from Shuttle ascent to Shuttle
orbit to Space Station, you have to accommodate
the different rhythms of the game.
The Russians have a phrase for when the Shuttle
comes to visit the Space Station.
They say the hurricane came through.
Because they have this nice orderly regime
and these folks come and fill the place up
and they're doing stuff and they're throwing
things here and there and then they leave.
And then we have to sort it all out and go
back to our normal kind of placid existence.
The last thing about flight planning is we
talk about decision making.
Here is the simplified diagram for the Chandra
X-Ray Telescope launch decision.
AXAF, as you might know, is the Advanced X-Ray
Astrophysics Facility which got renamed Chandra
Telescope.
And we have the ascent flight direction, we
have a mission director, we have the ops director,
we have the launch director, we've got the
KSC people and all these people.
Then the prelaunch timeframe are all watching
their parts of this.
They're watching the telescope.
They're watching the upper stage.
They're watching the Shuttle.
They're watching a launch complex.
Somebody has got to decide and they all have
got to talk to each other.
And they are all, by the way, geographically
in different places.
And you've got to know who is responsible
for what and who has authority to give information
for what.
Because you don't want somebody in the AXAF
control center saying to the NASA test director
your shuttle doesn't look right on TV.
He doesn't know that his TV is out of adjustment
or something.
The plan to get all these people together,
what numbers they call, what they loops they
talk on has got to all be worked through.
That is a real operational nightmare when
you come to decision-making and communications.
We have literally thousands of people involved
on a launch decision, a payload deploy decision
and looking at their piece part.
It has to be clearly defined what you're looking
at, what you're going to do if it doesn't
look right, and so you have to spend a conservable
amount of time planning that, training for
it and then executing.
And I think we ought to break here if we're
going to take a two-minute break.
Thanks, Jeff.
I hope this is helpful to you guys.
It is not exactly the standard academic fare.
I want to talk a little bit about systems
engineering because one of the things we pride
ourselves on in an operations community is
that we are systems engineers.
We're not mechanical, aero, what have you.
You're a systems engineer and you've got to
know a little bit about a lot.
One of my favorite authors is Robert Heinlein.
You may have heard of him.
And his quotation about what a human being
is I think is particularly appropriate to
us.
And somehow this didn't come off on the page,
but the bottom line is he comes out with specialization
is for insects.
I'm not going to go over the Shuttle.
You guys kind of know what it looks like and
why it got there.
I was looking at the syllabus of the class
thinking I should have been in this class.
Structurally, it is a complex vehicle.
Inordinately complex in my way of thinking.
But that is because of requiring wings for
the cross range, large aero surfaces for the
aerodynamics and, of course, being able to
transform from a rocket to an on-orbit spacecraft
to a hypersonic glider is not easy.
The main landing gear and the tires is a subject
that I could talk about for a long time.
And, in the interest of time, I took it out
of my presentation.
But if I ever get a chance to come back -- I
think you probably had a discussion of that,
but operationally they are a bear.
Al Louviere actually gave a nice talk.
Good.
We are the only folks that operate tires in
that regime, other than the Concorde.
And you guys know what happened to the Concorde.
And we have real constraints on our tires
and fret about them all the time.
Here is a list of the Space Shuttle systems
that we divide up into.
One of my favorites is right here in the middle.
Food.
But it goes everywhere from the main propulsion
system onto the waste management system.
Isn't that a great NASA acronym?
This, I think, is an erroneously named chart
because it says Space Shuttle Systems.
This ought to be Orbiter Systems.
There are many other systems in the main engines
and so forth.
One I would like to talk just a little bit
about is the environmental life control system.
I think you probably had a little talk about
that before.
Have you had an introduction to the environmental
system before?
I think it is a wonderful system.
Again, it is wonderfully complex.
We have water in the crew compartment so that
if it leaks it is not hazardous.
We have Freon out in a payload bay so it won't
freeze when it gets very cold.
And we have this ammonia stuff for the last
part of entry which is a pain in the butt
but it is what it takes to get there.
As you know the story, basically we take oxygen
and hydrogen in the fuel cells and make electricity.
And, as a happy byproduct, we make water.
My case study here is going to be what do
we do with the water?
These days, most of the time, we give the
water to the International Space Station where
they can electrolyze it using electrical energy
from the solar rays and turn it back into
oxygen, dump the hydrogen overboard and breath
the oxygen.
We probably made this stuff by electrolyzing
seawater so it is going this back and forth,
water to electricity to components.
I wanted to talk a little bit about what we
do with this water.
Some of the water is used as coolant through
the flash evaporator system.
It is very important to us but we typically
run in excess, and so we've got to get rid
of it which becomes a waste management problem.
If the crew doesn't drink it, we have to dump
it overboard.
As I say, we've tied into that system.
And typically we've used the very pure water
and give it to the International Space Station
these days.
I am sorry the print is kind of small.
But right here is the dump valve.
And one of these is the waste and one of them
is the supply water dump valve where we dump
that water out.
Now, you'll notice something very interesting
about that dump valve.
We have a window in a hatch and we've got
windows up here and we've got a TV camera
here and a TV camera here and nobody can see
what is going on.
Nobody can see what is going on coming out
of that dump valve.
The only way to see is to take the arm out
and put it in a very sensitive position to
look at what happened.
In the old days they used to teach drafting.
I always liked to look at these.
The computer did not do this drawing.
This is a work of art.
This is the nozzle.
The Shuttle was developed in the 1970s.
We don't have a CAD model of the Shuttle.
Jeff asked me could you send us the CAD model
of the Shuttle?
We had a little arrow CAD model of the outer
mold line that the aero people use.
There is no CAD model of the Shuttle.
It exists on 800,000 paper drawings.
And, when I came to work, one of the things
I got in the Program Office was a recommendation
from the independent people to go off and
computerize all of this.
And so we went off and tried to develop an
estimate to computerize it.
They said it would take us eight years and
cost about $40 million to convert these drawings
from paper to the latest -- What's the CAD
model that everybody uses?
CATIA.
I cannot remember.
We are not going to do it because we don't
have the money, so we're still working with
the paper products.
Anyway, here is the nozzle.
The water comes in.
There is an orifice and a set of heaters because
you've got space on this side.
And if you just push water out there it will
freeze.
You want to keep it from freezing so you've
got the heaters in there.
And this is a very tricky small orifice to
design, install and maintain.
Now, here is what Mission Control sees.
This is a plot of temperature, well, it's
actually three or four things versus time.
And what we have here is the first thing that
happens is you turn on the heaters on the
nozzle and the nozzle temperature warms up.
Then you open the dump valve and the water
supply quantity goes down.
And, as the water goes out, the nozzle temperatures
jitter a little bit, but they basically stay
in this nice, warm 150 degree temperature
range.
Close the dump valve.
The water quits flowing, the nozzle bakes
out, turn the heaters off and it turns off.
That is a normal water dump, what Mission
Control looks at all the time.
The crew has got a timer.
Or, better yet, Mission Control calls and
says start the dump now, stop the dump now.
Sometimes they'll set a timer.
Here is a little bit of an abnormal signature.
Turn the heaters on, the temperature comes
up, it plateaued out and it kind of does this
kind of thing, and people start scratching
their heads what is going on?
There is another interesting thing.
Here is one that warmed up, didn't get quite
as warm as it should have, sputtered out and
quit.
What is going on?
We actually took the arm out and looked at
this nozzle, and there was an icicle that
had grown on the outside.
And, if you go back to this little drawing,
it turns out there is an offset here.
And this nozzle has got a little offset to
it.
And they had rotated the offset 180 degrees
so that the heat wasn't being applied properly
and we were building an icicle.
And we built probably a 16 foot long icicle
off the side of the Shuttle on more than one
occasion.
And actually went out on one flight with the
arm and knocked it off.
Actually knocked it off like you would knock
an icicle off your eaves.
The thing that clued us into this, in addition
to these temperature plots, was the fact that
we came back with ice stuck to the top of
the payload bay doors.
There was actually a lump of ice that survived
reentry.
At the Kennedy Space Center there was a lump
of ice on top of the payload bay doors.
How would you get a lump of ice on top of
the payload bay door?
The reason is when this door is open, right
here, it hangs over.
And this icicle had grown all the way from
the gap from the nozzle to the open door and
had actually stuck on the open door.
And when we closed the door the icicle broke
off, people theorize, at the root and then
carried this long stick of ice up and reentered
that way.
And when we landed most of it was gone but
about a two or three pound ball of ice on
the doors had survived reentry.
Now, you might say, well, what is the big
deal about that?
We also found a big hunk out of the insulating
tile on the OMS pod where some of that had
broken off and had traveled back during entry
and struck the OMS pod.
This is not a good thing because you are depending,
in early phases of atmospheric flight, on
these thrusters for attitude control.
And their propellant tank is right there inside
that pod.
Not a good plan.
There is an example of a mystery in Mission
Control that we had to work our way through
over the course of, really, several flights.
And they redesigned the nozzle.
Here is the simplified drawing of the electrical
system.
I think you guys have seen some of these systems
things before.
We've got three fuel cells connected to three
main buses which branch out into all these
sub-buses.
If you are a flight controller you need to
understand how you get electrical power because
everything on the Shuttle works on electricity.
I am old enough now that I went to work in
Mission Control before the simulator had programmed
in the electrical system.
And I was a propulsion guy, OMS RCS guy, and
we practiced all this stuff about the propulsion
system and what would you do if different
things happened.
One day they released a new drop of the software
and all of a sudden the trainers could cause
electrical power buses to fail.
We didn't know what the heck was going on
but we learned in a big hurray because that
is a big important part of our job.
Here is a simplified picture of the communication
systems onboard the Shuttle.
This is the simplified.
Did you catch that?
Have you guys been through the communication
system?
We have S-band FM, S-band PM and Ku, and it
all comes in here and goes out there.
And it is all cross-strap so that if any one
of these little black boxes doesn't work the
integrated communications officer can send
commands and change it all around.
Unless it was the communications boxes didn't
work, in which case we've got to call the
crew on the other radio and tell them to go
throw some switches, which is very complicated.
And if you don't talk to the crew from Mission
Control you don't do anything.
If you don't get telemetry from the vehicle,
from Mission Control, you don't do anything.
If you cannot command the vehicle, from Mission
Control, you don't do anything.
You might as well go out and get a cup of
coffee because there is nothing you can do.
If the comm systems folks are having a bad
day -- And I will just add that's one of the
most serious malfunctions that we would practice
all the time so you had it cold.
I mean if most things, if they break, you
can talk to the ground, get some help, they're
looking over your shoulder, but if you cannot
communicate with the ground at that point
onboard your success in getting home depends
on being able to analyze what is the malfunction
and reestablish communication.
So, we take that very seriously.
And, I've got to tell you, this is a serious
design flaw in the Shuttle.
And here is a principle you need to remember.
When the systems were categorized
[NOISE OBSCURES]
they were categorized on the basis of the
severity of their failure mode.
Obviously, the main propulsion system is what
we call a criticality one system.
If bad things go wrong in the main propulsion
system really bad things could happen, so
they spent serious design effort making sure
that nothing bad would happen.
The communication system is a crit-3 system.
That means that people did not spend the time
to make a robust communication system.
It is not as reliable as some of the other
systems.
And that was a huge mistake.
And we have to fuss with this all the time.
That is a huge headache.
When you design something people say, well,
communications isn't critical.
Absolutely wrong.
Communications is absolutely vital.
You cannot do anything without communication.
A flight rule on the books says if we lose
all communication between a station and a
shuttle the crew must land within 24 hours.
And we keep updated with just enough information
so that they know where to land without communication.
That is part of the news you get every morning
is an update of if you lose communication
these are the landing sites.
That's right.
Here is where you want to go.
Here is the weather and here are the times.
This is the simplified drawing of the data
processing system.
This is the hardware of the data process system.
And you've got this general purpose computer
that goes out through all these data buses
to all these multiplexers and demultiplexers
to talk to all these different pieces of gear.
And we've got different buses to get into
each of the black boxes.
And you can switch ports and it is very reconfigurable
and is a big pain in the butt.
And if you want to operate as a systems flight
controller you have to understand it cold.
This is the software, very simplified high
level view of the flight software onboard
the computer.
You guys talk about the onboard computers
on the Shuttle?
OK.
How much memory does a general purpose computer
have?
512K memory.
Not megs, not gigs, K.
Of course, it works in ascent and vibrations
and radiation and all these other things.
Very sophisticated software in a very small
place.
What I grew up on is the reaction control
system.
This has got helium pressurization going through
a series of regulators and valves down to
propellant tanks which get manifolded out
to the various thrusters.
You've got oxidizer and fuel.
They come together and they make fire.
And so I started life as a mechanical engineer
specializing in fluids so I'm supposed to
understand things like pressure and temperature
and combustion.
But I had to learn about valves which are
mechanical and electrically operated that
are operated through the computer system so
all of those data buses on this page right
here became very important to me.
They are sometimes operated automatically
by the software so I have to understand all
the software.
And then we get to what we call we redundancy
management.
We have this basic principle that we want
to have more than one of a critical thing.
And so the question is how do you monitor
and manage that redundancy.
And the reaction control system has got the
most sophisticated redundancy management program
in the Shuttle.
And it depends on instrumentation coming back
through those multiplexers and signal conditioners
going to the computer that when it commands
through the digital autopilot those jets to
fire they either do or they don't.
And it tells it all about it.
And then the crew gets notified back over
here.
And it is very complicated, redundancy management.
Redundancy is a way to provide reliability.
Redundancy is not a means to an end.
I noticed Chris Kraft said that the Shuttle
is quad redundant.
That is not correct, Chris.
The Shuttle is not quad redundant.
We have four computers.
They are not quad redundant.
Now, if you go to a lot of systems, you only
have three of.
If you go to some systems that you have four
of, one cannot do the job.
For example, flight control.
We have four flight control hydraulic channels
that operate the elevons.
One channel cannot operate that.
It takes two.
So you've got four but it takes two.
That means I can lose two.
So, I am at best, three redundant.
I can lose two and fly with two.
The trouble is if you lose two and they get
in a fight with the other two it becomes very
difficult to manage.
One of my favorite systems is the inertial
measurement system.
The main requirement on Shuttle avionics is
that it is fail operational/fail safe.
You've got to be able to take the first failure
and you can keep flying the mission as planned.
You take the second failure and you're still
safe to land because you've got one left.
Three inertial measurement units, clearly
we are fail operational/fail safe.
Well, no.
If the first inertial measurement unit fails,
good to go, we keep on doing what we're doing.
But those last two, if they disagree, how
do you know which one is telling you the truth?
That is tough.
We developed this mathematical scheme using
matrices and the navigation quaternion that
would give us the best chance.
We have about a 99.5% chance of determining
which IMU is telling us the truth versus lying
to us, but it isn't foolproof.
It takes people to manage it.
We have opened ourselves, through redundancy,
to a system in some cases where we don't have
quad redundancy.
We have four ways to fail the system.
The reaction control system is one of my favorites
because we have four jets on each side.
For example, the yaw jets in the aft that
you need.
So, you would say quad redundancy.
No, I have four ways to fail.
What I'd really like to have is just one jet
that would do the job and was highly reliable,
but I've got four jets that are leaky that
get clogged up, that lie to you on the instrumentation
that you've got to watch all the time because
I need at least two of them to do the job
during entry.
So, be careful when you say things about redundancy.
What you're really after is reliability, not
redundancy.
Redundancy is a way to reliability.
And you build these incredibly complicated
schemes to deal with redundancy to provide
the reliability of the system level you need.
Simple is better, let me tell you.
Complicated is not.
I've got two stories from the trenches and
then I'm going to quit.
You guys have not been asking too many questions
so that either means I am a brilliant lecturer
or I'm putting you to sleep.
This is not your standard academic fair.
Is this good for you guys?
OK.
Yes sir.
I have a question on the redundancy.
Chris Kraft talked earlier this week about
how because you have four strings that you
should launch if one string is broken and
not worry about it since you're still failsafe
with what is left and that that would increase
the turnaround time and you would be able
to launch more often.
One IMU has failed, we'll launch with the
two because we know that 99.5% of the time
that is good enough for us.
Do you have any comments on that?
Chris and I have had this discussion before.
I have a technical response to this discussion.
Bullshit.
We are not reliable enough to launch with
anything down.
This vehicle is barely reliable enough to
make the mission as planned when we launch
full up.
If you want to build a spacecraft that needs
two of or three of or four of.
And you want to be able to launch with one
broken on the launch pad like sometimes your
airplane takes off with something broken that
you, the passenger, don't know, but the pilot
does and say it is OK.
We're not at that stage.
That is a nice idea.
That is a great goal.
I think people, when they thought about designing
the Shuttle, thought that we ought to do it
that way.
It doesn't work with the design we've got.
If you were going to build a new Shuttle,
yeah, I would put five IMUs on it.
Well, shoot, I would throw out the IMUs and
I would put GPS on it or something like that
because it is more reliable.
But we are not at a stage where we can launch
with less than the normal stuff.
Our flight history is that we have terminated
three Shuttle flights because we lost redundant
gear to the point where the flight rules said
you needed to come home.
Now, if you had launched with just enough
gear so that the next failure puts you into
shortened mission, you would have terminated
more flights early.
The whole theory about the Shuttle, if you
go back to the very beginning, we are going
to fly a flight a week.
What?
64 flights a year originally.
That didn't happen for a variety of reasons.
If you flew 64 flights a year, the theory
was if you got up there and something broke
and you had to bring the payload back, OK,
we would just role it into the one next week
and we would have enough flights.
It hasn't happened that way.
Spaceflight remains difficult because these
flights are rare.
The best we've ever done, I think, is ten
flights in a year in 1985.
And typically we're talking four or five flights
in a year.
These flights are rare.
The pressure is on to get the maximum advantage
out of every flight.
And I think spaceflights are going to remain
rare with the technology we've got into the
future.
That is probably a discussion for a future
date, but the fact of the matter is that Shuttle
does not have the reliability in its piece
parts to launch with one of things down.
JEFF: Wayne, let me ask you a question to
speak to, you know, just here at a classroom,
not as the Shuttle manager and not for attribution.
This is a danger, when people
[OVERLAPPING VOICES]
.
Sheila Widnall was here and told us about
CARB and their reputation.
What is your feeling about the wisdom of ending
the Shuttle flights at the end of the decade?
WAYNE: I have a couple of thoughts.
First of all, I am a Shuttle hugger.
I grew up with Shuttle.
Shuttle is an amazing vehicle.
It is a huge technological leap.
I am very proud of what it has done.
On the other hand, we need a replacement.
It has got some serious shortcomings.
And if you look at the history of aviation
and the first 30 years from the Wright Brothers
to, say, the DC3, that was about 35 years,
a little less.
DC3 was the first economically practical airliner,
right?
Everybody wanted to compare the Shuttle to
the DC3.
The problem is between the Wright Flyer in
1903 and a DC3 in 1935 or thereabouts, they
went through probably 10,000 designs.
They had trial and error.
We tried things out.
We found out what worked, we found out what
didn't.
They junked the bad designs.
They took the good designs, and they took
the good parts of the good designs and built
the next designs even better.
They probably went through 10,000 variations
on aircraft to get to that point.
Now, we've been flying in space for about
35 years.
Count them all.
Chinese, Russian, American.
How many space vehicles have there been?
Human space vehicles.
Less than ten.
Soyuz, Vostok, Voskhod, Mercury, Gemini, Apollo,
Skylab, Shuttle, Shenzhou, what am I missing?
That's about it.
How can you possibly advance that technology?
It is ludicrous to think that you are going
to advance the technology without doing the
iteration that we saw in early aviation.
We should have replaced the Shuttle 20 years
ago as a nation with a more advanced version
that fixed some of the shortcomings that made
it more economical to operate.
We should have done a lot of things but, for
national reasons, we didn't.
So, I am torn.
I love the Shuttle.
It is a great machine.
I spent my whole career with it.
It gives us capabilities that we are going
to give up, frankly, when we go to the CEV.
It's going to be a different kind of machine
that does different kinds of things.
And we are going to miss the Shuttle, I am
convinced.
But should we long ago have built a new one?
Absolutely.
Are we behind where we should be?
We need to invent the next generation of spacecraft
and be ready to go on and invent the next
one after that.
The Shuttle was designed for a ten year life.
We should have been working on Shuttle II
the day that Columbia launched the first flight.
OK.
That is my perspective.
Anybody else?
Yes.
This might be outside of the realm of the
discussion, but those 10,000 different designs
that were done for aircraft were done largely
by private sector, right?
There was a fair amount of government.
And, remember, it wasn't all American.
There was a large amount of government subsidy.
And it was, frankly, a cheaper technology
to develop.
Rocket technology is difficult to develop.
I will go back to Heinlein my favorite author.
He says when you're in earth orbit you are
halfway to anywhere in the universe.
Getting the first hundred miles off the planet
is very hard, but once you get in earth orbit
or thereabouts you are halfway to anywhere
in the universe.
And we still have not cracked that nut.
I really like the space elevator guys.
It is science fiction but the idea is a good
one.
There ought to be a different technology other
than rockets to get to space.
Somebody did a calculation that said if we
had an elevator to the Moon, we could get
to the Moon for about $10 worth of electricity.
Of course, there is a big "if" that goes in
front of that rolling that elevator.
So, rockets are an exceedingly difficult technology.
I want one of you guys to invent a new technology.
Aaron Cohen, he may have already told you
this, tells one of the great stories of all
times about spaceflight.
He talks about when he was in the management
of the Space Shuttle program and the fact
that the main engines were causing just awful
problems getting them developed.
Stop me if you heard the story.
And one day he woke up and said wouldn't it
be great if somebody just invented an antigravity
device and we could get away from rockets?
Wouldn't that just be great?
And he thought about it a little while longer
and said no, it would still have braised welds
and electronic parts and all the things that
are causing us problems on the engines would
cause us problems with the antigravity machine.
Get him to tell you the story.
He tells it better than I do.
But we need a better technology, quite frankly.
We need something that makes the transition
from propellers to jet engines.
We need something like that.
The Space Shuttle main engines in terms of
the rocket cycle thermodynamically are about
99% of the maximum theoretical efficiency
for a hydrogen/oxygen rocket engine.
You're not going to do any better.
We need a new technology.
You might make them cheaper, you might make
them more reliable but you're not going to
lift any more pounds to orbit.
So, we need that revolution.
OK.
Well, I'm passionate about it.
Anybody else?
Yes.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
You're talking to the wrong guy.
Of course it's a help.
If you want to talk about whether it's a hindrance,
ask him after I'm gone.
Some of our astronauts friends which we'd
shut up.
But, no, seriously, I think everybody would
say that Mission Control is actually a vital
part of the process.
You've got to plan the missions.
You've got to execute the missions.
There are only so many people onboard the
vehicle.
These are not autonomous vehicles.
That is another word that really sets my teeth
on edge when people say space vehicles ought
to be autonomous like commercial aircraft.
It just sets my teeth on edge.
Have you ever seen what it takes to plan a
commercial aircraft flight?
There are more people on the ground than there
are in the cockpit by a lot.
And I'm not talking about the baggage handlers
and I'm not even really talking about the
mechanics that keep it flying.
Everybody has got to plan the routes, got
to make sure that they've got the manifesting
right, make sure that they've got the fuel
right, all that planning process, you've got
to have people that do that.
Saying you're going to get by without that
shows a total ignorance of how the world really
works.
Now I'm beginning to sound like Chris Kraft.
I want to share with you a couple of stories.
This is something you ought to past on your
wall.
The last law of robotics.
The only real errors are human errors.
Mother nature does not make mistakes.
If you flew your airplane into a thunderstorm
and it crashes, was it mother nature's fault?
No, you were stupid and flew your airplane
into a place that it wasn't designed to handle.
Perhaps the weather forecaster gave you a
bad forecast.
Perhaps your weather radar was insufficient
and didn't pick up that nimbus cumulous cloud
on its radar, but it wasn't mother nature's
fault.
It was a human error.
They used to talk about in aircraft accidents
there were really three causes for aircraft
accidents.
There is pilot error, which we all understand.
The pilot turned left when he should have
gone right, you know, something much more
sophisticated than that.
Pilot error.
There is mechanical failure.
Mechanical failure can come for two reasons.
Number one, the aircraft was not maintained
properly.
I remember that Alaska airline jet that went
down because it had the mechanism in the tail
that had the long spiral grooved shaft and
they didn't lubricate it properly and it wore
off.
And finally they had no elevator control and
the plane crashed.
It wasn't maintained properly or it wasn't
designed properly.
It wasn't design properly to handle the environment
that it flew in.
So, mechanically.
Or weather.
Well, I submit that weather is not a cause
of an accident.
Weather is a human failure because you need
to understand what you're capable of operating
your vehicle in, and you don't operate it
in environments that you're not capable of
handling.
The only real errors are human errors.
It's either the pilot, the engineer that designed
it, the guys that didn't maintain it properly
or maybe the guys that didn't forecast the
weather right.
Those are human errors.
They are not acts of god.
You need to understand the environment you're
going to operate your spacecraft in.
Make sure you design it robustly so it doesn't
come apart.
Makes sure you design it so that it can be
maintained and you make sure the instructions
for the maintainers is done properly.
And, finally, you've got to train your crews
so they can pilot it properly.
OK.
One of the things that the Shuttle doesn't
do well is navigate on its own.
The Shuttle has an inertial navigation system.
We're trying to upgrade it to GPS.
We've been trying to upgrade it to GPS for
ten years.
Maybe we will get the next vehicle Endeavor
out of its maintenance depot period with GPS
and fly it with GPS, but right now we fly
it with inertial measurement systems.
Those inertial measurement systems, developed
right here at the Charles Stark Draper Lab,
have some drift in them.
After about a day their knowledge of where
the Shuttle is creeps off.
It creeps off enough so that you could not
reenter safely because the error in the onboard
knowledge of where the Shuttle is is different
from where the Shuttle actually is.
In addition to that, the integration over
time doesn't give you a good state vector
so we track the Shuttle from the ground with
radar and update what we call the state vector
position, velocity and direction, six components
at least once a day.
On STS-32, Mission Control screwed it up.
There is a long flight.
The ninth day of the flight the INCO officer
sent a bad command that caused the Shuttle
orbiter to lose attitude control.
And if the propulsion system had been configured
differently they would have run the little
jets.
If they had been on the big jets we might
have used up enough gas so that the crew could
not have reentered safety.
This is a serious error.
It also happened at about 3:00 in the morning.
I would offer to you that you ought not do
critical things in the wee hours of the morning.
Writing term papers, running somewhat hazardous
experiments are not things you want to do
at 3:00 in the morning.
That error was recognized and corrective actions
were taken immediately.
But, due to some other circumstances, it was
a near thing.
We were out of control and out of communications
for about ten minutes.
And this was in the middle of crew sleep.
What they did basically was to uplink a state
vector that told the computer that the position
of the orbiter was somewhere outside the Milky
Way Galaxy.
I mean it was that kind of thing.
OK.
Here is the story for the night.
This is 17 days, 23 hours to 18 days GMT.
This was in the early part of the year.
This is a one hour time period.
The crew is awakened in the middle of crew
sleep because an onboard smoke alarm goes
off.
There was no fire.
It was just an erroneous alarm, but it woke
the crew up.
Now, when you are the flight control team
and you are working when the crew is asleep,
your number one goal is to keep the crew asleep.
Don't let them wake up.
So, this flight control team has already failed.
They allowed an erroneous alarm to wake the
crew.
A little bit later the flight dynamics officer
says we need to reinitialize the state vector,
which is something that we normally do, about
once a day.
It is interesting that this is in the middle
of crew sleep.
Normally it is done when the crew is awake,
but the flight dynamics officer says we need
to uplink a new position and velocity sort
of vectors.
The flight director says did you do a good
job, Fido?
Fido says of course we did.
Flight say OK, you have a go to uplink that
vector.
The integrated communication officer gets
the word from the flight dynamics officer,
I want you to go to the computer and get vector
number umpty-ump and uplink it to the crew.
And the integrated communications officer
uplinks the vector to the onboard system.
Now, there is a check in the onboard system
that goes into a buffer in the computer.
And that buffer gets sent telemetry back to
the ground, and the ground computer compares
what is in the onboard versus what is sent
and they should be the same.
We send about 5000 commands in the course
of a two week flight, and normally they always
compare.
This particular time there was a problem,
some radio noise or something and the data
got scrambled.
And it came back to the ground and the computer
put out the little words "data reject".
In other words, the command that you sent
is not what is onboard, the integrated communications
officer.
The backroom is doing other things.
The guy in the front room, integrated communications
officer checks the display and says, for whatever
reasons at 3:00 in the morning, OK, punches
the button to send the execute.
In other words, move the data from the buffer
into the navigation software.
It is wrong.
But he just makes a human error and sends
it.
His backroom guy, because we always work in
teams, is doing something else and didn't
check his work.
Normally there is a check and balance.
Before you send buffer execute you say to
somebody else does this look OK to you, too?
They missed that check.
What happens?
They send this command.
The Shuttle thinks it is in orbit around,
I was going to say Alpha Centauri, but it
was a lot farther away than that doing what
we call local vertical/local horizontal hold.
Well, now it's doing LV/LH around the star
in the Andromeda Galaxy, I guess, and it goes
out of control.
Not fast.
Now, this doesn't tumble end over end.
It reaches three degrees a minute rate, which
is not a high rate but you're moving out of
your attitude.
Well, what happens?
When you move out of your attitude the antennas
are no longer pointing at each other.
The Shuttle antenna is no longer pointing
at the tracking and data relay satellite so
command, data, voice, go away.
Loss of signal.
The worst thing the flight director can hear
is loss of signal with the crew.
OK.
We got lucky because about ten minutes later
it just happened to be acquired back through
the satellite.
It just happened to be acquired back.
We got lucky and they called the crew.
The crew switched to a manual autopilot, turns
on the big jets, restores the attitude and
life goes back to normal.
The crew now has been awakened twice, by the
way.
They are going to be grumpy the whole next
day.
If the big jets, which use a lot of gas, had
been on in that ten minutes, we could have
used the entire entry allowance of propellant.
OK.
As anything there is always a chain of events.
The flight dynamics officer was unable to
do this navigation state vector prior to crew
sleep because of the vehicle activity.
In other words, they had been doing maneuvers
and they had to get the radars to track to
build a solution.
Plans were made to uplink the state vector
during sleep, which is not terribly unusual
but not the typical situation.
During a sleep period, and I don't know why
they put during a sleep period, we typically
can have telemetry dropouts and radio frequency
interference and conditions which cause telemetry
dropouts.
They were predicted because of the orbiter
attitude.
The antennas don't always point in the best
part of the antenna pattern.
That we're going to have that.
We had the onboard smoke alarm that woke the
crew up.
We let them go back to sleep.
This is the same thing I went through.
Twelve seconds after he sent the back command
the backroom guy this did trivial recorder
command and we saw that they were miscompared.
And this is really the key.
Seventeen seconds after calling up the display
the backroom attempted to question the decision
but too late, the button had been pushed by
seventeen seconds.
OK.
The flight dynamic officer is looking to see
if we get a good state vector on the board.
He didn't see on the board.
INCO said I sent it.
What's going on?
The data processing system officer reports
that the computers, both of them, the guidance
and navigation computer and the system management
computer are clocking internal errors.
They have a term for this.
It's called divide by zero.
Computers don't like to do that arithmetically.
They send an alarm.
The propulsion system officer reports continuous
jet firing.
The guidance officer reports that they are
huge autopilot errors and high vehicle rates.
When I said three degrees, I meant three degrees
a second, quite a lot.
CAPCOM says wake up.
CAPCOM, we need to tell the crew something
is going on.
Wake the crew up.
Voice link is normally disabled during crew
sleep.
Because every once in a while somebody pushes
the button and wakes the crew up during crew
sleep so we configure it so that we cannot
do it.
So we had to reconfigure the ground voice
system to allow the CAPCOM to communicate.
We lost the one satellite.
We had the wrong antenna selecting.
And then ten minutes everybody thought they
were dead.
We woke the crew up, they put the vehicle
on manual mode and life returned to normal
after the new state vector onboard.
That never made the press, I don't think.
It was directly caused by operator error.
He clearly did things outside of what he was
trained to.
And these are all nice little bureaucratic
words saying that everything worked like it
was supposed to except for the guy.
And here is what we did in our great bureaucratic
mode.
Procedures were updated.
Software was updated.
Rules were updated.
Consol handbook procedures were updated.
Work guidelines of making people work ten
or twelve days in a row on nine or ten or
twelve hour shifts, particularly on a nice
shift were revised so we let people off.
And, basically, what we did was we added more
checks and balances to the system.
Now, is that the kind of thing that you do
when you are designing a spacecraft?
Why would you design a spacecraft where you
had to update the state vector every day?
Why would you design a spacecraft that would
crash into the surface of Mars when it was
supposed to go into orbit around Mars?
You've got to be careful when you design your
system of the unintended consequences of your
operation.
And if you don't think very clearly about
what you're putting on the operators you'll
force them into positions like this, so you've
got to think about the operation.
Not just is the wing going to fall off because
the wind gust is going to exceed the structural
capability?
You have to think about the operations.
I've got one more.
Do we have time for one more?
If you can do it in two minutes.
OK.
This main engine combustion chamber, the main
engines have a computer that looks at sensors
that controlled our mixture ratio and things.
One of these sensors plugged up.
And they give you the 30 second version.
You can read it all.
The ground had been using a pressure check
with a little pressure meter that had a Neoprene
rubber O ring.
And, when they pulled the pressure gauge off,
it left the Neoprene rubber there and stopped
up the sensor.
And, because of that, the engine nearly shut
down in flight.
And, if Mission Control hadn't been paying
attention and disabled that sensor during
real-time, we would have done our first return
to launch site abort on that engine.
So, little things count for a lot.
Small instrumentation things count for a lot.
I hope this has been helpful to you.
Anybody got any other questions before I sit
down?
[APPLAUSE]
One question from the back.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
Well, my thoughts are: I'm excited that NASA's
got the goal of going back to the Moon and
Mars, I wish we'd never gotten away from that.
I'm working really hard in the Space Shuttle
program to free up money so that exploration
can do what it needs to do.
I'm not in a position to know whether they've
got enough to do their job.
It does look a little tight - I don't know,
time will tell.
But I'm just excited to have the opportunity
to head in that direction.
I'm going to give you the diplomatic answer.
Chris is retired; I still have to go to work.